[Music]
in today's eight on your side are you
driving one of the best or worst cars in
las vegas for holding their value given
the rise in car prices due to the
microchip shortage finding a vehicle
that retains its value can provide some
significant savings for you as a
consumer
the latest study by ic cars analyzed
more than eight million new and used car
sales to identify models with the lowest
and highest loss and value after five
years we have never seen the used car
market behave like this we've never seen
these kind of increases in used car
values analyst carl brauer says the
price of used vehicles has shot up in
the last year about 30 percent as a
result depreciation which nationally is
closer to 50 percent after five years is
now closer to 40 percent nationwide 37
here in las vegas the idea that they're
like stocks now and depending on which
one you bought it goes up a certain
amount in the past 12 months
is very unusual in the las vegas market
some cars retain their value and
depreciate far less than average and
some depreciate far more take the jeep
wrangler it tops the list with the
lowest depreciation after five years at
6.2 percent followed by jeep wrangler
unlimited toyota tacoma toyota tundra
and the ford mustang compare that to the
list of highest depreciation the nissan
leaf at 63 percent followed by the bmw 5
series audi a6 mercedes-benz e-class and
buick enclave it's always interesting
because there's different vehicles that
are popular in different regions and
it's clear that uh las vegas has both a
truck element to it with these two
toyota trucks being so popular but
there's also all that great off-roading
you can do and all that beautiful
scenery outside of las vegas and the
wrangler is going to be as hot or hotter
in that segment and in that city than
anywhere else
yeah and of course he says um the
mustang everyone loves their mustang out
here with this
open country as well i always thought
that it was uh the trucks ever since i
started driving i remember that my
uncles would always tell me get a truck
because it would never go down in price
everyone's always looking for a truck
yeah they certainly are some retain
their value and plenty of others don't
but that was pretty interesting very
interesting list and i saw obviously the
uh the tacoma that you said the tundra
and the ford mustang
i mean it's a great list there it is a
pretty interesting list but it's
interesting how things have changed so
much he said they've never seen this
happen with the used car market now he
does predict that it'll stay this way
until about summer of 2022. he says
nothing's really going to change for the
next six to nine months because of the
whole issue with the shortage and he
said during the pandemic since everyone
was using their electronics at home that
created the microchip shortage as well
with the car company so everyone's just
trying to catch up i wonder if that's
going to change with the electric car
it's just moving forward
good question christian interesting
thanks so much for joining us here for
eight news now at four we have